john dans notre ancienne piscine une
piscine qui a été totalement reconverti
dans le projet extrêmement innovant ya
ici des associations des artistes des
entrepreneurs des entreprises et c'est
toute cette émulation qui aujourd'hui
dans le grand bain de cette ancienne
piscine fera que nous allons vraiment
réussir à créer un nouveau lieu de vie à
saint wendel qui on devait définir cette
piscine en trois mots la piscine c'est
le grand bain d'innovation
[Musique]
a regroupé du groupe et de la jeunesse
on va pouvoir avoir un lieu aussi pour
bath
retrouver en famille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
j'ai été une chose ici au tout début par
avant qu'elle ferme je suis arrivé sur
scène géniale juste avant cette piscine
tiens j'ai des souvenirs
cette usine est du bassin voilà c'est
une bonne reconversion je trouve qu'au
mental
[Musique]
association crée des portières et donc
on est super heureux d'être dans ce lieu
aujourd'hui de participer à cette
inauguration d participer à ce grand
projet on a un bureau local avec du
matériel on a nos adhérents sont super
contents de ce projet là ça nous donne
aussi une certaine crédibilité sur la
ville auprès de nos adhérents
ça nous motive aussi aller beaucoup plus
loin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai été très impressionné en fait par
cette visite on pense vraiment rentré
dans une piscine et saad est
complètement transformé et traoré sont
impressionnants mais on voit toujours ce
côté peace il en fait rentrer dans le
grand bassin et pouvoir marcher par
quatre sa les enfants ils ont adoré
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]